Birth of a nation ist ein Film von Nate Parker
der sich natürlich bezieht auf den Titel
des berühmten Films von D.W.
Criffith, ein Stummfilm vom Anfang des vergangenen
Jahrhunderts, der die Geschichte eines Clansmanns
erzählte.
Und Nate Parker macht sozusagen das Gegenteil.
Er sagt, die Geburt der Nation, ist eine Folge
des Rassismus, auf dem alles was Amerika ist,
beruht.
Der Film erzählt die Geschichte eines Sklavenaufstandes
1831.
Nate Parker erzählt das als Heldengeschichte.
Und macht aus einer doch ziemlich komplexen,
grausamen, fürchterlichen Geschichte, die
mit göttlicher Eingebung und ähnlichem zu
tun hat, eine eigentlich ganz einfache comicartig
erzählte Geschichte, eines schwarzen Heldens,
der sich aufmacht gegen die Weißen zu kämpfen,
die sämtlich abzuschlachten, bis er von einer
unübertroffenen, unübertrefflichen Übermacht
seinerzeit erledigt wird.
Das ist künstlerisch sehr bedenklich, was
er da macht.
Aus vielerlei Gründen.
Er bedient sich sämtlicher Klischees, die
wir aus Südstaaten-Epen kennen und das alles
tut er aber ohne etwas mit diesem Bildern
zu machen, was darüber hinausgeht, was wir
wissen, dass in ihrer Zeichenhaftigkeit sie
sagen, Südstaatenplantage oder so.
Und dann gibt es das große Problem in diesem
Film der Frauen.
Es gibt die Szene, wie ein schwarzes junges
Mädchen auf dem Sklavenmarkt verkauft wird.
Sie ist fürchterlich zugerichtet, sie ist
ganz offensichtlich schon vielfach vergewaltigt
worden, wird angepriesen quasi zu weiteren
Vergewaltigungen eingeladen.
Und der Besitzer von Nat Turner kauft sie
dann quasi für Nat Turner, der sie dann heiratet.
Und das ist so wiederwärtig, dass eigentlich
der ganze Film damit schon erledigt ist.
Es ist ja so, dass damals dieser Sklavenaufstand
überhaupt keinen Unterschied gemacht hat,
wen er da eigentlich niedermetzelt.
Es wurden ganze Familien niedergemetzelt.
Es gibt Aufzeichnungen darüber, denn Nat
Turner hat das die Geschichte erzählt, während
er in der Todeszelle saß und auf seine eigene
Hängung wartete, die die Geschichte erzählt
und hat erzählt, wie sie zurück gegangen
sind und Babys auch noch zu Ermorden und das
kann man nicht so gut in dieser Form eines
ungebrochenen Heldenepos und der Selbstüberhöhung
des Künstlers, der das nun tut erzählen.
Ich finde den Film sehr problematisch und
muss abraten.